okay so last week AWS just took a huge
step forward in the generative AI race
they announced a whole bunch of new
tools for developers and they're giving
away access to one of their AI tools
completely for free in today's video
I'll first provide a quick recap of the
updates AWS announced last week and then
we'll dive into the top 5 AWS artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Services I recommend learning for each
service I'll be sharing what it does why
it's important and how you can use it to
build your own AWS Cloud project let's
get into it so starting off with the
updates one of the most exciting
announcements is the general release of
AWS code Whisperer you might have heard
of this service before because it was
announced back in June last year but
they've just made it free for everyone
which means you can now use it to
generate code provide recommendations
and identify issues all without having a
subscription plan you can kind of think
of code Whisperer as your own AI coding
companion similar to GitHub copilot next
up AWS announced Amazon Bedrock which is
a tool that helps developers build and
scale generative AI applications without
having to invest time and resources into
training Their Own Foundation models or
FMS it gives people easy access to FMS
built by AI startups including AI 21
labs and stability AI as well as
Amazon's own set of FMS called Titan
speaking of Amazon Titan it's a family
of models trained in-house by AWS giving
developers the opportunity to build
powerful AI tools there's currently two
models that have been launched but
probably with more to come in the future
at the time of recording this video
Amazon bedrock and Amazon Titan don't
seem to be available to the general
public but if you have a startup or
business you can fill in this sign up
form to express your interest so on the
same day of all of those announcements
Amazon also released two AWS ec2
instances one powered by the company's
inferential two chips and one powered by
AWS trainium by having instances that
are tailored specifically towards Ai and
machine learning use cases AWS will be
able to deliver better performance
whilst offering a lower cost now I think
it's pretty cool that AWS is providing
the underlying resources help customers
build their generative AI applications
because there's definitely been a trend
where companies are against the
employees using public tools like
chargpt in order to protect their
private company information and avoid
potential security breaches there was
even an article published recently where
employees have admitted to using
chagibut as a way to work multiple
full-time jobs but I feel like that's
just a whole nother problem altogether
anyways now that you're up to speed with
the latest updates I'd like to share
with you the top five AWS AIML tools I
recommend learning for 2023 as more and
more companies start adopting AI into
their workflows we're going to see a
greater demand for people who are up to
date with the latest advancements so
whether you're a job Seeker or someone
already working in Tech familiarizing
yourself with these AIML tools can
really give you an edge in the market
it's also just really fun to learn about
as well with all that being said let's
jump straight into the first service
which is AWS code Whisperer as I
mentioned earlier AWS code Whisperer is
kind of like your own personal AI coding
buddy all you have to do is integrated
into an ID like Visual Studio code and
then let it help you generate real-time
code suggestions what's really cool
about it is that it helps you identify
errors in your code and has built-in
security scans to help you detect
application vulnerabilities the reason I
recommend learning how to use code
Whisperer is because of how much faster
it can help you write code it will not
only help you save a ton of time but it
can also make sure code is written at a
high quality what's even better is that
AWS code Whisperer is optimized for AWS
apis like Amazon ec2 AWS Lambda and S3
so if you're using other AWS services in
your application code whisper can help
you work more seamlessly to get started
you can check out this free online
Workshop where you'll learn how to build
a fully fledged serverless application
for image recognition the workshop uses
code Whisperer and a bunch of other AWS
services like Lambda API Gateway
dynamodb and S3 I'll put a link to it in
the description below and if you decide
to try it out let me know how it goes
next up we have Amazon Sage maker this
was launched back in 20 2017 but has
gone through significant improvements
over the years sagemaker is like a
One-Stop shop for creating training and
deploying machine learning models on the
cloud you get access to Jupiter
notebooks for writing code building
machine learning algorithms and tools to
fine-tunior models all in one place
Amazon has been in the tech space for a
really long time where it started as an
online bookstore nearly 30 years ago and
so Amazon sagemaker is built upon all
the experience Amazon has gained from
their own products anything from
personalized shopping to customer
recommendations Robotics and so on I'd
recommend learning Amazon stage makeup
because the service lets you tap into
the power of machine learning without
having to be an expert in the field
companies like Airbnb grammarly and
Pinterest or use Amazon sagemaker to
build and deploy their own models and
with the growing demand of people with
machine learning expertise learning
Amazon stage maker could be a really
good start if you're looking to get
hands-on experience with Amazon
sagemaker you can check out this free
AWS Workshop that provides a great
starting point you'll begin the workshop
by creating a safe make a notebook
instance and then interact with it
through sample Jupiter notebooks the AWS
CLI and the sagemaker console and then
throughout the workshop you get to
explore different data sets create model
training jobs and set up endpoints to
make predictions from those models
another resource I'd recommend is this
12 hour udemy course that teaches you
about Amazon sagemaker feature
engineering and other machine learning
Concepts it does follow the curriculum
for the AWS machine learning
certification exam so once you complete
the course you could take the exam and
get certified the third AWS service I'd
recommend is Amazon recognition which is
specifically used to analyze images and
videos all you have to do is provide an
image or video and recognition will
identify the objects people text and
things around it this can come in handy
in many types of situations for example
if a company wants to check how many
people entering the office is wearing a
mask they can use Amazon recognition to
identify this through real-time video
streams so if you're interested in
visual data analysis I definitely
definitely think it's worth giving
Amazon recondition a try and as always
the best way to learn is by getting
hands on AWS has two free tutorials that
are about 10 minutes long and teaches
you how to use Amazon recognition in the
first one you'll learn how to detect
analyze and compare faces you'll be
given an image and then with recognition
you'll compare it with other images to
see if the faces belong to the same
person and then in the second one you'll
analyze a 30 second video clip of an
ultimate frisbee game as I mentioned
both tutorials only take around 10
minutes each so definitely give it a go
if you're interested in learning more
about Amazon recognition next we have
Amazon Lex a fully managed AI service
that makes it easy for you to create
chat Bots and conversational interfaces
it's kind of similar to charge ubt in
that it's designed to enable humor-like
interactions but Amazon lacks focuses
more on providing developers a platform
to build conversational interfaces into
their own applications so every time
you're on a website and you see a little
chat with no pop-up asking if you have
any questions chances are is is probably
built with a conversational AI service
like Amazon Lex as we've all seen with
chai gbt chatbots are on the rise and
can be a fast way to answer common
questions or help complete a simple task
with Amazon Lex you could build customer
support systems reservation booking
tools or even a personal assistant to
increase your productivity to get
started I'd recommend working through
this Hands-On tutorial that teaches you
how to create a chat bot for a banking
application you can see that the
tutorial will cost less than two dollars
and it takes about two hours to complete
and then once it's done it should look
something like this and you can interact
with it by typing in messages last but
not least we have Amazon comprehend this
is one of my favorite AWS Services
because it's pretty much like your own
AI power detective that can unlock
hidden inside some text items like
documents social media posts and
customer reviews it uses sentiment
analysis to understand emotional tone or
sentiment expressed in certain sentences
which is quite important for companies
who want to figure out how their
customers feel about their products and
Services learning about Amazon
comprehend lets you dive deep into what
customers are really saying without
having to read one sentence at a time
and over time as more data is generated
insights can then be provided with more
accuracy so if you're interested in
Amazon comprehend and want to get
Hands-On with it you can take a look at
this comprehend immersion day workshop
and work through the labs this immersion
day is a bit longer than all the other
workshops so definitely don't feel the
pressure to complete everything all in
one go alright so there you have it five
AWS AI services to learn more about in
2023 and Beyond if you've watched this
video all the way through please give it
a like and comment below which AWS
service you're most interested in
starting to learn alright bye for now